[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
emmanuel macron rempile pour cinq ans au
terme d'une campagne éclair inédites
voire improbable entre kobe des gars en
ukraine jamais l'élection présidentielle
n'a semblé si peu intéressé les français
sous la vème république
deux sénateurs ont fait campagne dans ce
contexte il y a d'abord cet homme
françois patriat
ancien socialiste rallié à en marche il
est un peu l'incarnation de la politique
à l'ancienne dans le nouveau monde macro
nist à 79 ans c'est la der des ders pour
cet intime des manuels macron le
deuxième homme philippe moullier du
genre rigoureux et appliqués dans
l'ombre de valérie pécresse ce
technicien est l'homme de confiance de
la candidate et l'air de lourdes
responsabilités ont reposé sur ses
épaules le volet handicap du programme
mais surtout les comptes de campagne de
la candidate de la droite avec eux nous
remontons le fil de leur campagne dans
les coulisses d'une élection qui ne
ressemble à aucune autre
[Musique]
c'est parce que vous allez voir
aujourd'hui bien solution absolument pas
celle qui était prévue par les équipes
des manuels matmut pour cette première
journée du salon de l'agriculture c'est
un passage qui aurait dû être un
événement dans ce début de campagne du
président puisqu'il était prévu qu'ils
deviennent candidat désire tout casse
avait été comme ça
à six heures de suite à l'arrivée il
arrive à ses limites si c'est pas le cas
c'est normal car on va à la tête qui
rend peut-être qu'un discours y revient
il inaugure la gauche et il s'en va 8h15
8h30 ben mahmoud
la guerre revient en europe et nous nous
voyons aujourd'hui dans un contexte
inédit grave et historique
et c'est ce qui fait vous m'en excuserez
que je ne tiendrai pas l'agenda qui
était initialement prévu et je laisserai
le le premier ministre et le ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation à vos
côtés
john est donc comme l'année dernière
c'était fermé la première constituée de
ne pas être les grands vins
j'ai le sentiment ici et que président
est venu le premier ministre se promène
dans les allées du salon avec une
franche bonne amie paradoxalement alors
que nous avons un climat international
terrible alors qu'on pourrait penser que
la campagne est là autour je trouve que
ce salon est un salon plutôt apaisée
[Musique]
à 14 heures qu'il arrive là non
outre-mer
attendait
et désolé
ah non mais
je deviens préparé avec mes amis on
savait qu'on a un groupe ultra marins
sénat donc préparé que la groupe ultra
marins dès que georges patient d'autres
la venue du premier ministre pour parler
des problèmes de l'outre-mer
spécifiquement qui attend en outre mer
donc j'essaie en avant d'aller voir un
peu pour synthétiser des questions que
les faire revenir vers le premier
ministre voit l'acheteur d'avant-garde
fantassins de la macro ni monatte
réviseront jouable le stand de
l'outre-mer d'où vient le premier
ministre est chez vous
est ce que georges patient est là est-ce
que vous avez des sénateurs d'outre-mer
tu viens au stand outre-mer
il va pas être là avant 1h30
est-ce que vous avez vu monsieur
patients le sénateur non
georges la parole
je suis sénateur de la côte d'or et je
cherche ou et georges patient vous
l'avez vu
ce matin c'est que quand ça va bien
aller pour macron bon alors mais
normalement on fait pour lui
mais la liste
non mais va gagner mais
je soutiens c'est vrai j'aime des
campagnes électorales j'aime aller
convaincre j'aime aller convaincre
j'aime aller me battre pour des
convictions j'aime pas les menottes pour
un président pour qui j'ai une
admiration sans limite
georges fait une heure que je t'ai
cherché
j'ai fait j'ai fait campagne pour mâcon
dans tout et par département de fils de
parents paris d'argent même si
bien
monsieur le ministre c'est du bon en
fait tous les stands on a été faire la
campagne de vos enfants
se passe bien très bien tu vas bien
arrivé tôt ce matin 6h30 c'est bien tu a
compté le nombre de salons que tu as
fait 49
48 opposé les 15 49 salon
cgi si je venais déjà ici je venais déjà
ici accompagné les animaux nous faire
apprécier comme veto après je suis ni
veto après je suis venu président de la
commission agricole du département la
côte d'or je suis venu députés après je
suis venu ministre centre et l'yonne 1
le furent commises la veille du choc si
tu prends des cuirassés l'année j'étais
avec la capitation jeu léché fait
c'était juste avancé dès 2002 et s'était
c'était à moi dans le matériel je me
souviens vous l'avez dit elle est
arrivée vers les aubrac et m'a dit tu
avais françois comment je tape sur le
cul des vaches
je fais mieux couché avec mes nerfs au
fond des choses
[Rires]
[Musique]
pour
bonjour
oui c'est ça
juste
sur
fond d'accord
mon idée était donc gelé par la
mort ce matin donc aller vite et son
collectif handicap donc je participe là
une mission ou web tv
qui a un objectif à la fois de présenter
le programme de notre candidature et ps
en matière de handicap a donc cette
émission va commencer d'ailleurs par une
vidéo de 10 minutes environ de valérie
pécresse qui porte un message et ensuite
je suis là pour répondre à ça tombe de
questions compléter l'intervention
donc j'ai pas remettre les pieds sur la
table
je peux demander enrichir
ce que je souhaite c'est pour nous qu en
urgence aurons nous puissions vocaux
finalisation l'individualisation
bonjour et merci pour votre invitation
lorsque valérie pécresse pas demandé
d'être un peu le porte parole de ce
sujet là c'est pascal a considéré que
c'était un objet essentiel dans la
couche chaude accompagnée des politiques
qui devaient est en tout cas pris en
charge
mais souvent
c'est pas encore l'été chez déjà bronzé
est-ce que c'est pas un peu frustrant
quand on techniciens comme ou de bois
par exemple des sujets comme l'ukraine
complètement phagocyté le débat s'est
pas concerne pas que le handicap pour
moi bien que la compagnie toran
aujourd'hui un peu en ce sens bien parce
que la plus apte et des français est
tourné vers l'information qu'ils ont au
niveau international avec beaucoup
d'inquiétude ont subi comme tout le
monde on subit à la fois la cité
internationale et l'impact est direct
sur la campagne présidentielle
très bien mais coûte et bonne
continuation
à bientôt
la toile
[Musique]
hier soir
l'insoutenable suspense a été levée
ce maquereau est candidat mais c'est un
bon candidat on voit bien quelle va être
la stratégie de tenter de dissimuler le
bilan qui fut le sien durant ces cinq
années et de s'abriter de façon un peu
cynique derrière la crise internationale
monsieur macro n'a jamais été le
président de tous les français jamais
[Musique]
le salon
viendra encore les élus
[Musique]
très bien soit c'était même plutôt
plutôt bien là bon c'est un temps
combien aujourd'hui je peux pas
exactement en 1900 à 2000 je crois salut
revenus c'est une journée de campagne
donc là ici à chartres avec les élus
nous et ensuite dans les deux-sèvres
département avoir l'occasion des crieurs
boudreau taille aux poudres et au public
sera chassé qui dure en forme écoute
mais je suis parce que ce soir 2000
grâce à damien temps voilà s'avère que
zénith c'est bien mise en place est un
battant deco niveau du retail où tout le
monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
emmanuel maman et le modèle d'un
président de la république tout à la
fois monarchique et dictateurs valérie
par rapport à son âpre au fer par
rapport à son fonctionnement personnel
permettra de sortir de cette arrogance
du fonctionnement du pays qui l'a
enfermé au niveau de paris pour faire à
nouveau respirer nos territoires
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui mes amis je vous le dis
emmanuel macron astrac tueur et la
france l'heure du choix enfin sonné
alors je vous le dis vous pouvez compter
sur ma totale et entière détermination
[Applaudissements]
voilà je propose d'installer ici
c'est le bon papa manens l'intégriste
celle de ses voeux le dépeint avec
monsieur macro mais voilà je pense que
vous allez pourquoi aujourd'hui il ya
une crainte certes c'est important et
même avant il n'avait pas envie de
débattre il ya cinq ans je me souviens
très bien c'est une campagne escamoté et
s'il ya une seconde campagne qui est à
nouveau volé aux français ça peut péter
parce que quand un peuple s'exprime pas
dans les urnes il peut s'exprimer
beaucoup plus violemment ton ami
eh bien
tu manquements ça va
fédéral de chart's
ban a alors ces vers sont un peu les
cartes c'est pas parce qu'on dit in
grande vie que
ont fait danser les femmes comme on
chante la marseillaise les yeux rivés
sur lui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mandela
non
de toi
l'audio
non
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs si vous voulez
nous rejoindre dans cette famille pour
tracter boîtier est vraiment pour faire
gagner notre candidate valérie pécresse
bravo
[Applaudissements]
très actif comme chacun y trouvait des
deux vallées il a conseil avec son
expertise sur le dossier handicap et
l'épaule avec la responsabilité confiée
par valérie de l'association nationale
qui finance sa campagne
chapeau
bien
tout d'abord beaucoup de joie beaucoup
de plaisir de vous retrouver retrouver
des visages connus d'autres visages
nouveaux enfin mon char bruno j'ai le
sentiment aussi que nous sommes en
famille enfin enfin
la campagne électorale peu près le monde
discute et
enfin daniels l'a dit tout à l'heure
nous connaissons
l'ensemble des candidats puisqu'il y
avait beaucoup de mystères notamment
pour mener le maquereau la qualification
au second tour elle se fera dans un
mouchoir de poche à à l'emprunt de près
alors bougez vous bougez vous est
convaincu autour de vous il la
république et une avance
[Applaudissements]
mais dans la cinquantaine
l'aide dans la santé
[Musique]
aujourd'hui par personne non il ya
personne qui sort du lot
pourquoi pas ce que vous répondez
panneaux attendu de terrain auquel vous
êtes beaucoup trop loin de tutu tout le
monde mais que regarder filippi les
prochains jours oui parce que c'est un
ami et comprenait alors voila mais vous
savez quand même les gens qui vous rend
politiques qui vont un peu loin ils
oublient les gens les gens dans son
élan et elle l est pas trés on l'a vu
tout le monde lui a reproché que le
zenit avait été raté tout simplement
parce qu'elle est moins à l'aise
derrière un pupitre ce que dans l'action
et qu'est-ce qu'il faut préférer moi je
préfère quelqu'un comme ça plutôt que
notre présent république est un des
comédiens
[Musique]
hier qu'il était en forme hier son
président oui
nous allons à la maison de l'aveyron
c'est à lui que je vais découvrir je
connaissais la maison de l'aubrac mais
la maison de l'aveyron ça me va bien
parce que c'est un des départements
français que je préfère aujourd'hui
c'est le lancement de la campagne ces
lancements avec les parlementaires
galvanisés un peu les trous de fil
machine que le président veut dire il
faut y aller tous à fond rien n'était
écrit rien est acquis
ceux qui pensent aujourd'hui que le
président se sert de la guerre pour
faire campagne je trouve qu'il ya dans
cette attaque une part d'intimité
je vois mal aujourd'hui les français
accepter de voir un président courant de
podium en podium de drapeaux un drapeau
pour se faire applaudir devant des
militants et c'est pas l'opposition qui
l'a convaincu que les français il a dit
je m'adresse aux français c'est un drôle
de campagne
c'est pas une drôle de campagne c'est
une campagne présente on aurait dû et
dans la fin du coc vide en phase de
libération de retrouver des jours
heureux d'être optimiste on se retrouve
avec des incertitudes terrible des
incertitudes qu'on imaginait plus revoir
depuis des années
non mais pour vous c'est pas drôle de
faire de faire ce film que dans les
conditions on le fait aujourd'hui parce
que le président on le verra pas
beaucoup un mieux on le verra pas
beaucoup
en
fait la ola
damien
les avale tout va bien aujourd'hui ça va
bien le président l'a
31 dans leur ligne il faut polling 31 5
que le pen encore a dit non
non pas dans les labels tombe à 15
équipes est restée derrière mélenchon
oui
fallait
bien qu'elle vient le 22e là bas il
paraît que c'est une grosse grosse
journée mois peut-être les ordinateurs
comme je fais des déplacements même
temps je dois aller même jour dans les
ardennes ne sais pas où je reviendrai
pour dîner
si je suis pas dans la journée qu'ils
vont
bien mieux ce sera un décembre
[Applaudissements]
la mort
[Musique]
au revoir bon alors il nous reste un
point à traiter donc le gie au président
de la commission nationale des comptes
de campagne que l'on reçoit demain matin
à 11 heures une idée c'est là qu'on lui
parle mon problématique mais surtout peu
eu à nous dise un petit peu quels sont
leurs points principaux d'attention
bataille pécresse m'approcher un rôle
spécifique c'est une marque de confiance
a donc de présider l'association de
financement de sa campagne électorale on
veut nous mettre en relation avec la
personne de la préfecture qui va nous
donner la date prévisible de
remboursement par l'état du
remboursement forfaitaire de l'état dans
quel endroit car notre budget de la
campagne électorale devrait osciller
entre 14 et 15 millions d'euros je
rappelle que le plafond autorisé de 16,8
millions d'euros on a tiré sur le sur
l'emprunt que valérie a acté l'hypothèse
la plus défavorable c'est le 10 avril ça
veut dire que premier tour le 10 avril
ça fait des intérêts qu'on aura de
précompte et jusqu'au 10 janvier moi
j'ai un sujet qu'il faut la poser demain
c'est la question de la prise en charge
les déplacements les bons jeux soient
très claires je trouve l'algérie sont
sur ce point ce comprend compan compte
les pays dans lesquels on ne peut pas
faire quand même initialement mais on
peut quand même en forme et l'asie
france et d'étranger donc par prudence
on a surtout on a sécurisé mais la
sécuriser mais de poser la question mais
leur poser la question ce serait pas mal
que ça reste quand même un point est
tout à fait ok le combat donc on est
tous les six présents demain voilà je
conjugue aux joues le bal ont fait un
tour de table pour dire qu' autour de la
table on voit un peu on les laisse
pense-t-il entre durs aussi de sujets et
puis voilà j'imagine bien au dessus tout
rond dans l'est dans la démarche est
patron devant la caméra là un échec
juste des chèques
voilà donc ça se passe ici voilà c'est
la salle ou à la fois en solo document
elle toujours les financiers
administratifs paiements tout se passe
ici
[Musique]
nous sommes ici aux docks de paris en
banlieue parisienne c'est ici emmanuel
300 journal ils sont en train d'arriver
au fur et à mesure et sont accrédités
pour cet événement
on doit avoir des règles qui réussit
encore davantage au retour à l'emploi ce
sera la réforme de ce qui est
aujourd'hui le rsa y aura dans cette
réforme l'obligation de consacrer 15 à
20 heures par semaine pour une activité
permettant d'aller vers l'insertion
professionnelle la réforme que je
souhaite mener c'est
d'augmenter l'âge légal progressivement
de mener cet âge légal jusqu'à 65 ans il
est républicain estime que votre
programme pilule heures est ce à dire
que le programme de madame pécresse
était bon je m'en fiche
royalement
totalement présidentielle mans ce qui
compte c'est ce qui fonctionne pour le
pays ce qui est juste ce qui le rend
plus fort ce qui permet aux françaises
et aux français de vivre mieux pour ce
qui est du reste
si à ce point ils ne savent se
différencier du projet que je porte
compte ils étaient faire dans cette
galère
[Musique]
l'abeille chapek que les médias car tous
nous fait ressortir que les sujets qui
fâchent il est sujet qui suscite
polémique contestation qui font perdre
du poids est le bon il faut expliquer
comment la retraite c'est pas la
retraite que dans les questions de 5
lauren ou retraite à 55 ans en retraite
à 62 ans il y aura un contrepartie du
rsa l'attribution à la source de toutes
les aides sociales à tout le monde ce
qui va être encore une mesure de
simplification à hauteur d'homme comme
il y en a eu tout au cours du
quinquennat
très bien bon alors très grande journée
des gens là je me passerais bien
l'itinéraire est tellement serré le
temps est tellement contraint les
rencontres tellement prévu que c'est
difficile au milieu de satisfaire tout
le monde surtout quand il ya deux
déplacements et demi dans une campagne
il y en a eu plus loin enfin
voilà quoi
là on va avoir une cet après midi de
rencontres dans la foule comme il en a
eu des dizaines des centaines au cours
de cinq ans donc
j'imagine que le président aimerait bien
en faire plus
bonjour
bonjour bonjour
avec tout ce que j'ai entendu sur mes
relations avec françois fait la photo de
mariage
[Rires]
je souhaite que le vote pour emmanuel
macron soit un vote d'adhésion pas
uniquement un vote utile ça vote
d'adhésion un vote de confiance et ce
que j'attends des électeurs
sociaux-démocrates qui comme moi appelle
à voter pour lui faire travailler sa
jambe gauche entend conserver j'ai pris
cette formule oui oui c'est vrai c'est
vrai il faut deux jambes pour marcher et
il faut pas oublier la jambe gauche est
très importante on le voit partout en
europe donc la social démocratie elle
est présente et elle doit être présente
aux côtés d' emmanuel macron go
[Musique]
quand on marche comme vous le savez
c'est un projet que j'ai depuis le début
quand on marche il faut deux jambes en
feu une à gauche ni à droite il faut en
mettre une après l'autre pour pouvoir
avancer donc je suis heureux moi que et
je remercie que que françois rebsamen
soit à mes côtés et fait ce choix et de
le voir aux côtés de aujourd'hui à mes
côtés au côté de françois patriat qui
m'accompagne depuis depuis six ans et
qui était avant cela aussi dans la
famille socialiste m a rejoint et je ne
le dira mieux que moi mais je ne crois
pas qu'il se sente est déséquilibré
alors tantôt certaines mesures ont une
couleur de droite tantôt une couleur de
gauche c'est la cohérence d'un projet
qui compte
est ce que vous trouvez normal la
facture de gaz elle est passée à 60
euros à 100 euros elle a augmenté depuis
presque 50 euros par durant combien de
temps va là au mois de janvier j'étais
assistante sociale
moi c'est insupportable
mais qu'est-ce que
des jaloux dans les fonctions comme ça a
changé pour vous lancez pas c'est
impossible de vivre ça c'est ce que je
fais je le dépense
emmanuel dont j'avais à chaque fois
qu'on descend s'il ya des gens qui
veulent me poser des questions il va il
va aller voir quand il ya des
contestataires il veut les convaincre
jamais ça c'est un c'est comme ça depuis
sept ans à chaque déplacement j'ai fait
avec lui s'il ya des drapeaux s'il ya
des opposants côté dessin aussitôt il va
les rencontrer
d'autres y seraient ils seraient fait
déposer plus loin en retrait dans la
salle et ne rêver personne
y'a un truc est tombé luxe espagnol
vous avez votre épaule avec vous
aujourd'hui françois patriat aller
exactement c'est un bon terme justement
poser toujours là landes m ça va
on va rentrer le lab s'en va commencer
la discussion s'il vous plaît vous êtes
tous drapés je couds vraiment dix mois
welch est un messager de son appétit en
campagne le cop ailleurs fait sept ans
que son compagnon
on arrive on arrive aujourd'hui à la
briser et c'est sans doute ma dernière
campagne
savoir si on change la constituent et
kim et elliot
et c'était que vous puissiez en tout il
a été échangé avec les responsables
associatifs qui vont vous vous soumettez
à la question même l'habitude et donc si
j'avais monsieur vous me demandez je
suis
là nous rencontrons actuellement des
gens qui sont qui sont impliqués dans la
politique de la ville des gens qui se
bat bien animer les quartiers qui sont
là pour aller chercher les jeunes qui a
des missions locales qu'il ya des
entreprises d'insertion
et puis il va susciter les questions
pire à chaque fois encore ici communes
comme le communisme tout temps il a
réussi à convaincre face à tous ces
défis comme en affaires on doit pas non
il faut aider à parler davantage les 65
ans c'est l'âge de référence aujourd'hui
en italie et en espagne c'est pas
choquant et surtout c'est ce qui va nous
permettre de monter dans le tram minimes
alexandre ce mondial des dispositifs
sociaux mais évidemment les matins ces
dispositifs sociaux ce que je vous ai
dit mais ces dispositifs sociaux que
vous les payez pas s'il ya quelqu'un qui
travaille pour y montrer dans la répéter
d'efficace model helena l'auteur de ces
valeurs quand elle est des destins se
faire malbec
c'est là où on en est fiers et c'est
tout ça
[Applaudissements]
merci
nous avons
mais qu'est-ce qui est en difficulté
dans les sondages yann ipsos simon un
film social nomme sous la barre des 10 %
elle a contracté de kobe de la candidate
7 et républicains érotique c'est encore
un obstacle de plus sur sa route on
s'était simplement pas ça veut pas ça
veut pas
[Musique]
je crois que tu montres que tu as fait
un point avec la roja oui mais dans les
territoires c'est important nos
populations ont besoin pour que l'on
confère fort de dignité après attention
particulière égales à celles portées ou
aux autres territoires ça va être ma
finale surtout que là on est à quelques
jours de l'échéance un cirque au fur et
à mesure qu'on se rapproche de la date
du premier tour le calendrier devient
terrible compliqué et c'est vrai que
comme il ya beaucoup de sollicitations
beaucoup d'interventions et bien qu'un
peu de temps d'essai de tout mettre dans
les jeunes à seulement sa donald est
particulière on a aussi tout un vrai
développement la sécurité morale
c'est naturellement une peu compliqué à
la fois plein d'espérance parce que
quand on se bat pour des valeurs qu'on
accompagne candidate et bien on est
vraiment dans une démarche positive et
en même temps ce sont des moments
difficiles on voit bien que la campagne
escamoté par l'actualité internationale
on a connu le commis depuis maintenant
l'ukraine on voit bien comment donner
les jeux politiques soit difficile la
médicalisation et parfois aussi
compliqué donc c'est un ensemble de
difficultés mais je crois que l'idée
c'est voilà on est combatif jusqu'au
bout on porte le message jusqu'au bout
on porte aux convictions et l'idée
serment d'accompagner valérie jusqu'à
jusqu'à l'échéance du premier tour
j'avais
voilà et allocations familiales dès le
premier enfant et ado et
défiscalisation des prestations
familiales des pensions alimentaires si
jamais la robe
à tous les gens qui disent que votre
campagne se termine et c'est plié qu'est
ce que vous leur répondre je leur dis
que les français sont libres et que
aujourd'hui la droite authentique celle
qui porte des solutions pour rétablir
l'ordre faire les réformes que le pays
attend et régler les questions de
pouvoir d'achat sans faire exploser la
dette valoriser le travail c'est nous
mais
c'est la volonté
[Musique]
bien des gens c'est bien
l'image président était en forme ça
c'est pour que ces fermiers jours sans
parler des cours se disent mais regardez
le pen a monté et macro baisse un peu
yahad deux mois mâcon était à 23 le pen
était à 17 aujourd'hui la croûte à 28 il
a pris cinq points elle a pris cinq
points le problème de la dynamique créée
parce que partout les drapeaux les
canons bien sûr mais quand annoncent
leur retraite quand annonce le propre
panoplie rsa qui perd trois points ça
c'est le prix de la clarté pour rappeler
qu'il est au
courant sa démonstration
va la soutenir sur train de faire un
deal
moi je ne le crois pas allez on peine à
4 h 45 gym chrono mais je suis pas comme
vous mais moi je vraiment je la vois
petit 43
simple que ça c'est plein de saison
individuelle où chacun va se dire c'est
pas si grave si je donne la peine non
c'est pas si l'europe en tant qu'artiste
vote le pen mais se dit ça
dans la guerre
pouvoir d'achat des français ça s'est
calmé un
canton quelqu'un qui te dit je mets la
tva 25 à 5 5 je bosse je bloque les prix
l'énergie augmentent et salaires c'est
quelqu'un de sensé peut croire ça dans
un
espace écoute a beaucoup changé les
choses pour elle parce qu'ils aient de
l'argent mais oui d'accord elle c'est
pas des gens sensés des gens qui les
gens qui nous aiment pas même pas le
président au cas pas de sens avec des
gens qui n'aiment pas le président tong
a autant qu'ils l'aiment tant à 30% qui
le détestent et 30% qu'il aime bien les
30% milieu sont pas prêts à jouer au con
c'est marrant tu que pourtant j'habite
en milieu rural où le fonds était élevé
depuis 83 donc ça fait 40 ans qu'il est
levée je sens pas comme ça qu'il faut
parler de son entourage ainsi parce
qu'il ya marine le pen
[Musique]
une bonne partie
comment peuvent pas
c'est les sondages qui se resserre l'osé
la question comme tel je vous dis la
description que fait peur pour mobiliser
nos amis si je vous ai pas peur d'abord
un père inversement je pense qu'on
aurait tort de passer de l'euphorie à la
fébrilité en dix jours il ya deux jours
tout le monde le disait bas valais les
amis c'est pas la peine et la gagner pas
t'en fais pas et c'est toujours dit mon
dieu oh là là attention regardez
maintenant le paiement et entre les deux
il ya la lucidité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moscou 30 et heures de temps le temps
ça
ravissant
c'est bien
aujourd hui
même famille du
gérant près d'accord du tout a mis au
parfum division et la débauche
il
des fonds s'est abîmé pour qu'on soit et
non plus et on
[Musique]
tu pas être cette personne et du son
[Applaudissements]
la m les hérité alternative se sont
banalisés dans le débat public nous nous
sommes habitués
nous sommes habitués à voir défiler sur
certains plateaux de télévision des
auteurs antisémite d'autres raciste
maniant à longueur de journée dans
davantage de lait si ce n'est pas
de les siffler par ton d'ateliers dans
les idées
je compte en effet en campagne il
affronte l'extrême droite je suis très
content vu l'écart avec marine le pen se
resserre au second tour dans les
sondages est moche je raisonne pas comme
ça et d'ailleurs il a eu des propos très
clairs là dessus en disant qu'il écoute
et niestlé triomphalisme ni les
cassandre en a je pense que c'est
exactement ça qu'il faut faire j'ai vécu
ce moment je veux dire pas seulement
avec émotion j'ai vécu avec envie puis
en fin de compte conclusion mobilisation
générale
mobilisation générale
[Rires]
[Musique]
bonjour mon école meeting de même la
montée directe son pavillon 6 et à
gauche
ça va
[Musique]
faire bien
d'accord
la garde au mieux le savoir faites quoi
ce que j'attends aujourd'hui c'est que
valérie puisse à la fois nous redonner
sa vision de la france et les éléments
phare de son projet l'ambiance de ces
derniers jours située à la fois une
ambiance où on sent déjà extrêmement
motivés et en même temps inquiet parce
qu'on sait bien que la campagne est
difficile vois dans ma culture je fais
partie de ceux qui refusent de réfléchir
à la défaite qu'on ne croit pas et
littoral c'est comme un combat enfin on
va jusqu'où va bien
et qu'elle était bien occupé avec des
caméras
place
et vous verrez on va avoir une super
[Musique]
pendant cette campagne
valérie a concentré toutes les attaques
elle a été la femme à battre
nicolas sarkozy
je ne voulais pas je ne voulais
absolument pas cette réaction bien au
contraire vous devriez l'ap le dire
parce que c'est lui qui a fait le
grenelle de l'environnement
à peu près cinq personnes rassemblées
ici bien loin très loin des quartiers
qu'ils étaient capables par exemple de
rassurer nicolas sarkozy en 2007 nicolas
sarkozy kbr et c'est un fait politique
était copieusement hué sifflé par
plusieurs centaines de jeunes visiteurs
ici tout à l'heure au moment des
premières prises de parole nicolas
sarkozy restait toujours totalement
sciences où ne s'aventurent pas
candidate et sa famille politique et
forcément ça crée beaucoup de rognons en
matériel
[Musique]
messi
[Applaudissements]
mes chers amis des élections
présidentielles nous avons nous en avons
beaucoup vécu mais des comme celle là
jeannerod
permis ya plus d'une politique ya plus
de code d'honneur la trahison est venu
l'arrêter pour un banal qu'on trouve
normal qu une campagne présidentielle se
résume à une campagne de débauchage
qui sera le prochain candidat la gamelle
matrone yens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ans
c'est un énorme changement par rapport
au zénith c'était lentilles zénith
ufolep sans oublier cette image attendez
moi j'en ai assez on n'est pas dans ce
vol s'est pas à chaud la vie politique
c'est la vie des gens qui est en jeu
merci
la campagne de pub
sur trois régions
c'est une autre bonne prestation à 0,15
ça donne une envie de combattre et voilà
c'est d'aller à droite tu vas l'avoir
cherché les vois les yeux après les
autres je fais partie de ceux qui sont
fidèles et donc mobilisés jusqu'au bout
jusqu'au des moments
[Musique]
arrêtez
ça y est à voter allez bon ta vie la
beauté j'espère je compte sur toi tu vas
bien à midi voilà vous en prie
ça va les amis bonjour
bonjour
bonjour là bonjour ça va ça va ils m'ont
tous ah ouais bien bien daniela ge s'est
pas mal passé et puis ça marche bien le
ton souvent ouais t'es
ok
oui ok
merci
aux habitudes at on pas jamais très
forte et il est déjà très bien merci
savez moi je ne doute jamais ce qu'on
tient doute n'y a pas de doute je n'ai
jamais douté depuis déjà sept ans la
capacité d' emmanuel macron tabor d'être
élu et d'être réélu cette fois donc je
ne m'embarrasse pas de ce genre de
sentiment
[Musique]
je suis le monde mais ces dames
à voter
beau courage j'attendrai le sms des
résultats de vos oui
non messieurs marois la butte art
bat dont on attend que ça se passe là
bas c'est compliqué
[Musique]
ouais
ouais mais gt gt j'ai fait un peu de
bateaux c'est une forme de soulagement
parce que cette ça se termine quoi voilà
donc les efforts ont été portés pendant
six semaines voilà se traduisent par le
vote au moment de l'élection au moment
du vote eh bien on espère toujours un
résultat favorable voilà donc j'ai le
même sentiment là conscient des
difficultés j'ai beaucoup d'espoir pour
ce soir nous verrons
ben écoute on verra bien on verra d'ici
ce soir c'est ce soir verra bien lorsque
j'ai reçu c'est difficile mais voilà je
suis parti il faut avoir des surprises
il peut voir voilà ce que je disais tout
à l'heure que l'élection des débats fait
pour les peaux boudeuse
à botter l'expression du jour pour ce
premier tour de la présidentielle les
bureaux de vote sont ouverts jusqu'à 19h
au planteur dans les grandes villes le
taux de participation amitié
s'établissait à 25 points 48% un tour en
baisse de 3 depuis 17 dès 2012
je m'entends tu
t'entends pas dans le truc à l'eau
non mais ça marche pas
dis-moi taux de participation ces deux
pointus 2002 trois points
et c'est en dessous de 2010 est quand
même
assez beaucoup d'appoint mais chez moi
ça vote énormément il ya déjà 50 % de
votants à 11h
le pen
n'avait pas peur hier et a peur ce matin
en fait l'analyse globale que je le
donnais oui vote utile à gauche
mélenchon
jadu ne fait rien tous les micros
candidats ne font rien
ça fait mal parce que je veux dire
pour nous qui venons de la gauche mais
bien on fait des bons scores dans les
endroits où les l'air sans fard
le premier dans les territoires
ultramarins c'est mélenchon assez
mélenchon et le pen derrière mélenchon
le pen derrière son sens martinique donc
scène ou en asie
peut-être que ces gens-là rêve de
rejoindre le venezuela
t'as pas appelé thon mais rachel
n'ont ils donc comité de soutien mme
pécresse a justement dit devant lui l'
pas comment il semble que ce soit arrivé
à remontant
je pense que on aurait pu gagner cette
campagne électorale mais les difficultés
très nombreuses peut-être trop
nombreuses trop nombreuses pour une
seule personne trop nombreuses pour
notre candidate il ya plein d'éléments
qu'on a subi la concentration des
attaques sur valérie pécresse pour
l'imaginait mon nom mais je n'ai pas ce
niveau là les ralliements maquereau en
cours de campagne souci des monts
difficile même si tout ça on est préparé
mais en train de préparer vivent ça crée
aussi des difficultés puis après je vous
dis le contexte international tellement
bouleversée que vous pouvez pas
l'imaginer
[Musique]
cas ce modèle coûts brutes non corrigées
em 24 marine le pen 24 mélenchon 19 elle
répétera suite zemmour est vite on a vu
des chiffres sur la boucle moi non mais
attends qu i kiss qui a sorti ça parce
que moi je dis aux mouches au qg est
occupée au qg on me dit aucun chiffre
n'est vrai
ils ont leur sourire enfin
alors le problème c'est qu est ce qu est
ce qu est ce qui m
24 24
ici tout est contradictoire donc je ne
sais pas ce qu'elle arrive tous les
jours j'ai pensé que d'effets nocifs
voilà c'est ça
donc j'ai dit attendons qu'on était
frais chiffres quoi que ce soit parce
que par les avants c'est inutile et
ridicule
[Musique]
on verra si l'unité de la droite raciste
au verdict des urnes valérie pécresse
devrait s'exprimer vers 20h30 nous dit
donc et vient d'arriver ici à la maison
de la cheville et où elle va prendre
connaissance des premières inspirations
du jour là sont les quelques tendances
mais il faut toujours très prudent voilà
on est comme très proche des sondages
qui avait été invoquée à première vue
donc on va attendre d'avoir les derniers
résultats
je sais pas
ou pas de guerre
cela
roger est possible
rochus
on se réunit cinq
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai un peu ce premier tour vous voyez
des les deux qg avec l'expérience que
j'ai voici la suite avait averti un
montant plus important
le ménage
soyons nous pouvons faire le choix de
l'espoir le 24 avril nous pouvons faire
passer gagner d'abord a surtout pas il
ya un vrai soulagement ce soir néanmoins
et pour bien qu' il faudra encore aller
chercher toutes les voix parce que le
chemin pour les de 28 à 50 il est encore
long
accor a dit que je vous allez bien oui
oui parce que je pense qu'il faut il
faut aller au contact et et je pense que
le pays on voit bien avec malgré tout
est divisé on est en tête vos ya plus je
pense de nos compatriotes qui nous ont
fait confiance qui a 5 ans qui était ce
qui est une force je le prends aussi
comme un le témoignage de reconnaissance
du travail fait mais je suis aussi
lucide sur le fait qu'il ya beaucoup de
divisions dans le pays donc je pense
qu'il faut apprendre de ça et aller à
les convaincre avec beaucoup d'humilité
j'ai dû batailler sur deux fronts contre
le camp du président sortant et contre
celui des extrêmes et malgré les
profondes divergences que j'ai martelé
tout au long de la campagne
je voterai en conscience emmanuel macron
pour empêcher l'arrivée au pouvoir de
marine le pen et le chaos qui en
résulteraient de ce sport est très
faible on est en outre eu même des
estimations qui avaient été donnés donc
forcément voilà ce soir c'est un moment
compliqué difficile
sauvegarde mains au savon politique
c'est l'avenir la droite samuel b a
l'air tellement l'avenir des partis
autres que le parti du promat unique
parce qu'aujourd'hui revient que
l'alternative ce sont uniquement les
extrêmes
[Musique]
la situation financière de ma campagne
est désormais critique nous n'avons pas
atteint les 5 % qui nous permettrait
d'obtenir les 7 millions de
remboursement de l'état que nous
escomptions je suis endetté
personnellement à hauteur de 5 millions
d'euros c'est pour cela que je lance ce
matin un appel national ou dont
personne n'a imaginé d'être en dessous
de la barre des 5% on voyait bien que
les derniers sondages de mener à un
niveau n'était pas satisfaisant on
parlait de 8% 9 % non pour ses pas avoir
un score aussi bas ce scénario n'était
même pas dans nos esprits
du côté du parti politique il n'y a pas
de difficultés le parti ne dépende était
coincé pas ne s'est pas endetté plus que
de ce qu'ils ne pouvaient c'est pas là
dessus les difficultés aujourd'hui la
vraie difficulté elle est sous les sacs
puis en grèce voilà j'ai vu les scores
nam à versailles c'est un truc de fou
mélenchon devant devant pécresse
bonjour moon a prévenu que les t3
nous allons au siège des républicains
pour le bureau politique d'après
élection on sent bien que celle r il ya
aujourd'hui deux lignes politiques une
qui appelle clairement à voter pour
emmanuel macron et une deuxième qui est
plutôt dans le refus de participer et
donc le ni-ni l'un et l'autre en moi je
suis plutôt clairement favorable aux
barrages alexandre watts vous en espérez
quand même quelque chose aujourd'hui
moi ce que j'espère c'est que même si
les hausses sont différées c'est certain
qu'on est en tous les cas une volonté
d'union au sein de notre famille
politique
puisque je vous dis y'a que ça tombe
dessus j'ai quand même qui nous
rassemble et donc c'était pour moi un
point important
[Musique]
je
le respect